[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir les trois ans transition
fixée au burkina faso après plusieurs
heures de discussions les 350 délégués
présents aux assises nationales ont
adopté la charte de la transition
une charte ensuite signé par le
président nous serons à ouagadougou dans
ce journal la mobilisation des proches
de françois bay a en république
démocratique du congo trois semaines
après son arrestation le conseiller
spécial du président tshisekedi est
toujours en détention il serait
soupçonné d'avoir fomenté un coup d'état
les détails dans un instant enfin nous
parlerons des premiers étudiants ghanéen
évacuer d'ukraine leur avion a atterri
ce mardi à l'aéroport international
d'accra certains ont commencé à raconter
leur calvaire les détails dans un
instant
il faudra attendre trois ans avant le
retour à l'ordre constitutionnel au
burkina faso c'est la durée de la
transition fixée lors de des assises
nationales qui ont rassemblé les forces
vives du pays 350 délégués au total qui
ont adopté la charte de la transition
notre correspondant à ouagadougou
kalidou sy a suivi pour nous ces assises
écouter un peu plus d'un mois après son
coup d'état qui a renversé l'ex
président roch kaboré polhenri sandaogo
damiba va troquer son costume de
président du rpr pour prendre la tête de
la transition burkinabè une transition
de 36 mois soit trois ans et il faut
dire que cette durée de mandat a été
entérinée à la suite d' assises
nationales ou les 350 participants ont
pu trouver un consensus au bout de la
nuit de lundi à mardi quelques
désaccords comme la composition des
différents organes de la transition ou
la gratuité des mandats ont pu retarder
la signature de la charte de la
transition autre décision 25 ministères
et 71 membres doivent constituer les
autorités législatives de la transition
toutes recevront un salaire pour leur
travail contrairement à ce que la
commission technique avait proposé je
vous propose maintenant d'écouter une
des participantes des assises nationales
la présidente des organisations
féminines du saen de plus aux rites et
d'un autre c'est la sécurité la sécurité
des personnes la sécurité des pieds est
vraiment un regard très spécial selon
lui la région du sahel le retour de la
représentation de l'état dans les
diverses localités du burkina et ensuite
vraiment au final mes yeux voire prom a
amené les déplacés chaussures parce que
ça c'était primordial pour le
développement et l'avenir même de notre
pays prochaine étape pour le président
damiba la formation d'un gouvernement de
transition
une nouvelle équipe gouvernementale qui
devra convaincre la cedao avec une
feuille de route viable aux yeux de
l'instance régionale et ainsi échapper
au spectre des sanctions
on va rester dans la région du sahel on
ne va pas parler sécurité mais climat le
giec le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat tire la sonnette d'alarmé dans
son rapport la baisse de la production
agricole qui va toucher tout le
continent concernera davantage le sahel
le niger en particulier pourrait faire
face à une des ses pires crises
alimentaires les précisions de notre
correspondant à niamey or le dire
si le réchauffement climatique dépasse
1,5 degrés ici au niger les premières
populations touchées seront les
populations des zones rurales celles
dont l'accès à l'eau est le plus
compliqué
l'urgence climatique les nigériens à la
connaissent en réalité depuis de
nombreuses années avant de fuir
l'insécurité avant de fuir le djihadisme
ils fuyaient déjà la fin la crise
alimentaire très dur entre 2011 et 2012
en est l'exemple le plus probant après
une sécheuse une sécheresse très
difficile toutes ces populations se sont
repliés vers les centres urbains les
experts ici considère souvent que les
effets dans le sahel du réchauffement
climatique sont imparables sur la
campagne agricole nous avons eu une
détérioration de la qualité de la saison
de plus qui se manifeste par et des
démarrages très hésitant qui peut se
passer sur un an de trois mois nous
avons une augmentation des séquences
sèche nous avons est dans la même
campagne pouvait avoir sur un même point
et une augmentation des séquences vous
pouvez avoir de la chaire et vous pouvez
aussi avoir des inondations sur dans la
même campagne le rapport du giec
conforte les conclusions de plusieurs
organismes le programme alimentaire
mondial par exemple ou encore action
contre la faim parlé ici au niger de la
plus grave crise alimentaire depuis plus
de dix ans
on en vient à la mobilisation des
proches de françois bay a en république
démocratique du congo le conseiller
spécial en matière de sécurité du
président tshisekedi est toujours en
détention cela fait trois semaines qu'il
a été arrêté par les services de
renseignement il serait soupçonné
d'avoir fomenté un coup d'état la
correspondance à kinshasa de clément
bonin
françois weill et avait été arrêté à son
domicile le 5 février dernier par les
agents de l'agencé nationale de
renseignements la nr trois jours après
la présidence congolaise dans un
communiqué avait évoqué je cite des
indices sérieux attestant d'agissements
contre la sécurité nationale
depuis des perquisitions ont eu lieu et
les enquêtes se poursuivent mais on ne
connaît toujours pas avec précision
quelles charges pèsent contre celui que
l'on surnommait le monsieur sécurité du
président félix tshisekedi sa famille et
ses proches réclament donc sa libération
c'est un prisonnier politique parce que
les nerfs lorsqu'il est alors qu'elle
est à les arrêter mais c'est françois
béa on sous-entend qu'elle avait déjà
des preuves mais pourquoi pas le
transférer des ressources naturelles
respectez au moins le délai de détention
au niveau des lots bgi 48 heures nous
sommes rodés l'un est donc ces droits
sont violés systématiquement et chaque
jour et s'inquiète un état de droit que
nous voulons aujourd'hui tels que le
président a prôné certains proches de
françois meyer ainsi que des médias
congolais évoque l'hypothèse d'un
règlement de comptes entre les
conseillers du président félix
tshisekedi on reprocherait à françois
bay à d'être trop proche de l'ancien
président joseph kabila et sa gestion
d'un conflit min à l'automne dernier
avait également été critiqué la
présidence de son côté n'a pas réagi à
la déclaration du collectif de ce mardi
et évoque un dossier entre les mains des
services de renseignement
cette décision de justice au maroc le
parquet a requis ce mardi en appel la
peine maximale de 10 ans de prison
contre le journaliste omar a dit
condamné en première instance à six ans
ferme dans une double affaire
d'espionnage et de viol il a toujours
contesté les faits la semaine dernière
c'était le rédacteur en chef du journal
arab al yom qui a été condamné en appel
à cinq ans de prison pour agression
sexuelle une accusation qu'il a lui
aussi toujours rejeté
en tunisie un premier groupe de 100 6
étudiants est arrivé ce mardi à tunis à
bord d'un avion militaire affrété en
provenance de bucarest et puis ces
images également en provenance du ghana
un premier groupe de dix-sept étudiants
évacués d'ukraine sont arrivés à
l'aéroport international kotoka d'accra
leurs familles et les ont accueillis
avec soulagement certains d'entre eux
ont commencé à raconter à leurs proches
leur calvaire le calvaire qu'ils ont
subies sur place l'oncle d'un étudiant
témoigne écouter
yauque nem il a quitté l'ukraine et il
m'a raconté les difficultés qu'ils ont
rencontrées
la discrimination raciale on leur a
interdit de prendre le train on leur a
interdit de prendre le bus et bien
d'autres choses encore
c'est formidable que nous ayons ce
programme ça montre que le ministère
prend certaines choses au sérieux mais
c'est la pagaille parce que les
autorités auraient dû réagir avant
maintenant les étudiants sont dispersés
en ukraine donc c'est très difficile
pour eux de s'organiser et sous les
bombes bon bon bon bon on est perdus
c'est traumatisant
après l'appel à la raison de
l'ambassadeur du gabon à l'onu c'est au
tour de celui de la côte d'ivoire de
mettre en garde contre les comportements
racistes que subissent certains
étudiants africains qui tentent de
quitter l'ukraine écoutez mon pays
appliquent des personnes d'origine
africaine fuyant la terreur qui s'abat
sur elle sont l'objet de brimades du
traitement à relents racistes si ces
informations étaient avérées il aurait
des raisons de se poser des questions
légitimes sur cette attitude pour le
moins discriminatoire
et inhumaine
c'est le lieu d'inviter les restes
ratissant des pays amis qui s'adonnent à
ce comportement a fait preuve de plus de
retenue de tolérance et d'un support
d'humanité dans ces moments de défi pour
toute la communauté internationale
au maroc c'est demain que le premier
avion transportant des étudiants évacués
d'ukraine devrait atterrir à casablanca
de nombreuses familles avaient tenu un
sit-in à rabat devant le ministère des
affaires étrangères on me demander de
l'aide aux autorités notre correspondant
jean marie lemaire a pu rencontrer un
couple dont le fils était unité était
étudiant en ukraine ils ont pu le
joindre par téléphone écouté
mon coeur de maman et meurtri je
n'arrive pas à me concentrer sur les
choses banales du quotidien je ne dors
plus et quand j'y arrive je fais des
cauchemars
je suis installé à ni pro
je pensais pouvoir y rester
j'espérais que les tensions elles
évitent s'apaiser
mais non
l'armée russe y est entrée dans la ville
et nous avons entendu plusieurs sirène
d' alerte
alors j'ai décidé de partir avec mes
amis
dès maintenant que vous êtes à la gare
là oui oui le train vient d'arriver il
faut que j'y aille à thoiras d'accord
mis d'accord c'est bien
j'ai vu un t il y à du thé ici oui parce
qu'il fait froid ici
donc il va franchir la frontière de
moundharia et la frontière de la
roumanie compte il arrive à la remballe
et je vais voir
réservez-les oublié de l'oublier d'avion
pour nous rejoindre à kazan
est ce que je
j'espère
et à ce moment là vous pourrez souffler
enfin enfin con qu'il arrive on va faire
la fête
il y a les africains qui veulent quitter
l'ukraine et il ya aussi les ukrainiens
en vacances sur le continent qui veulent
rentrer chez eux certains souhaitent
retrouver leurs proches d'autres
souhaitent tout simplement se battre
notre correspondant à zanzibar yacoub
talib a rencontré des touristes bloqués
sur leur lieu de vacances récit de
chimie sidbon
leurs vacances se sont interrompues
brutalement en congé sur l'archipel de
zanzibar
lorsque la russie a envahi leur pays ces
ukrainiens cherche à rentrer chez eux
rapidement mais les vols sont suspendus
notre fils et à kiev avec mes beaux
parents je ne sais pas comment nous
ferons partir le rejoindre
retrouver leurs proches se battre contre
l'envahisseur russe chacun a ses raisons
pour rentrer au plus vite
nous ne voulons pas être dans un autre
pays
nous voulons être en ukraine pour
protéger notre patrie nous voulons nous
battre
ils sont coincés ici n'ont plus d'argent
pour payer des nuits d'hôtel
supplémentaires ou même pour s'acheter à
manger
la guerre ne les dissuade pas de partir
ils veulent être en famille le
gouvernement de zanzibar cherche à aider
ces touristes
nous sommes en contact avec
l'ambassadeur les tour opérateurs et les
hôtels
nous voulons leur proposer des vols pour
des pays voisins de l'ukraine et nous
avons demandé aux hôtels de les loger
dans ces moments difficiles
ces touristes espère qu'une fois en
ukraine ils trouveront bien leur
logement encore debout malgré les
bombardements
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique merci et de nous avoir suivis
merci aux équipes en régie merci à notre
chef d'édition célia carrasso
[Musique]